hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm
Christopher Corbin we're so happy to be
here today we are announcing our gay
marriage and no one else is marrying us
but none other than Mel Gibson Mel
Gibson the man himself he said he would
never do it but we finally convinced
them that gays okay so why will we watch
any other trailer besides the remake of
one of Mel Gibson's movies or sequel I
don't remember but one of you guys is
gonna kill me they're skinny in his
wrong I heard it is like a sequel okay
well anyway honey honey you're getting
me mad you're okay I'm like max I won't
get you mad like get ready for those
jokes for the rest of our lives there's
nothing wrong with
our world is fire and blood everything
is dependent on killing
if they come again
everybody's gone out of their mind
[Music]
I'm not the only one max oh your
everything hurts you want to get through
this which is I say
they'll pick up this kid
[Music]
they died
[Music]
[Music]
Nicholas Hoult
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah that looks pretty [ __ ] sweet
that looks amazing I couldn't believe
that they actually had like the real
cars and stuff it's all real yeah it's
like they actually had like real effects
there and like a Vienna it looked fake
but it still was amazing yeah for the
stuff that obviously needs to be CGI to
get certain shots like yeah but for the
stuff where they're like can we do this
like make it look real by doing real
things watching the car sequences and
the cars flip over they built like
awesome vehicles yeah look like they
built an entire world like all those
cages and things yeah picking them man
the whole thing just looks like
incredibly haunting and so menacing - I
saw the music there like that look ha Oh
like just made you really like want
again you do like I'm like oh man I feel
like I'm watching a Star Wars trailer
like for the episode one where like it
is yeah you were seeing them fighting
with the late like with a double
lightsaber there's like ah [ __ ] it's
crazy but it was that was a letdown
hopefully this won't be a letdown like
that imagine it won't be I mean they got
the original director just like how they
got George Lucas for episode of what
they are they got the original director
that does not say it's going to be new
it hopefully will be it looks amazing
but I just respect about the trailer in
general is they're not advertising it
like how they would advertise any
Hollywood summer blockbuster yeah
they're like showing the actual tone in
vibe and the weirdness of this movie
which I really respect because it's like
they're saying like the fact that it's
weird and trippy and apocalyptic is the
reason why this movie will sell the
actions cool looks like I mean they
don't really show you this story but it
doesn't matter like you don't really
need to see that much like we all know
what the story is it's a
post-apocalyptic world and you get to
see like really what I I wouldn't say
what would happen if it actually we went
to shed because I doubt people would be
driving muscle cars yeah fire going out
of them or there would be a water world
I don't think any of that's gonna happen
well maybe you know no climate change
man climate change could it could happen
Mad Max snowy road I have to bring this
up as I still love Mel Gibson I don't
know you feel but I I'm still a fan of
his work his politics I would question
most of the time really primarily his
politics and his view
the world and how he treats people is
the main reason I like Mel Gibson his
movies I'm so so about I'm just not a
fan of his racist rants what about his
phone calls to his wife that was the
funniest prank ever uh I wasn't a huge
fan of those because it didn't feel like
a prank
big money prank ooh you are defending
him so hard
some people are gonna hit the road to my
house cuz now they're feeling the fury
anyway yeah I don't know how they do a
lot of these new reboots these days but
I'm just gonna say this I don't know if
this max is the same [ __ ] Mad Max I
think it's the same Mad Max and they're
gonna actually like write it into the
script that he took a bunch of steroids
and got like really jacked up and so now
he's like a huge pleasure yeah he got
like Botox injections he went through a
whole deal he lost his accent because he
went to America to like study for a
little while in study abroad and like
the post-apocalyptic world and then he
came back and he had a different accent
but the same [ __ ] was going on so he had
to like come and defend the world again
the old post-apocalyptic world just like
he did in the first one so that's pretty
much the story of where what we got from
him looking like Mel Gibson to him
looking like Tom Hardy did you not read
that article that when it comes to Mel
Gibson and Tom Hardy I think Tom Hardy
is a fantastic actor I really do
oh he's made but I don't think he can
pull off the same light and he doesn't
have to but I feel like Mel Gibson would
just have that like [ __ ] star
charismatic presence I would argue that
but this is probably a different type of
movie - yeah cuz I've seen him I've seen
Tom Hardy do some amazing stuff not just
Bane but like his older films I'm glad
he's actually getting his due from like
all the work that he's done he had a lot
of hit Indian films for a while and then
he just finally started blowing up so
it's nice to see him actually working
and getting good role and actually I
take back what I said yeah looking back
at Tom Hardy's work I I feel like a
total [ __ ] idiot for saying that scene
Bronson Oh Bronson if you haven't seen
Bronson we're plugging Bronson right now
and Charlize Theron zanuck committing
like hell to it - I didn't recognize her
at first and I remembered that she's
she's an Oscar winner
she's not sure whether she's brilliant
and there's that black over her eyes
when I showed her like when it cut to
her yeah oh I was like ooh she looks so
good and Nicholas Hoult as this like
what the [ __ ] was he I don't know oh he
looked like one of those Prometheus
creatures I did not recognize him at all
and when I saw it was him I'm like oh
[ __ ] he's going to like completely
change for this performance I'm excited
this whole can be pretty [ __ ] amazing
and sometimes he's kind of whatever but
a lot of time he's pretty damn good well
most of the time I see my scene playing
really intense
and it looks like in this one he just
went like I'm gonna go balls-out crazy
with this character and be like a cycle
that's what was cool about it it looks
like craziness but these dudes are
committed to yeah you know it feels like
it's a serious film but they're having
fun but they're fully committed to the
reality of this world yes I can't wait
to see it well guys caught up on
shoutouts but if you want a shout-out
you want us to mention your name in a
[ __ ] video one day customize it make
it personal go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts where you can say
something interesting and earn yourself
a way for me to talk about you because
they asked your privilege we love to put
your name so please send us the weirdest
names that you have yes the butcher and
dick pics if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the reel rejects we
have a lot of videos and Chris Corbin
few things about this guy you can catch
him on Jane the Virgin reoccurring role
Monday nights on the CW at what time
Chris
it's a 8 central 9 Pacific and eastern
so 8 9 central no 9 8 central o 9 8
central look it up also for the other
thing you wanted me to mention which my
brain is right now so I am starting to
teach improv intro to long-form improv
at Mile straw workshop in Hollywood if
you're interested in signing up for a
year-long program to study with some of
the best teachers in LA for doing
long-form improv go to Myles improv comm
or email us at mile straw workshop at
gmail.com we look forward to hearing
from you
that is like the first real plug I've
ever done
Wow you really prepared that no no that
was actually all improvised I did not
plan any of that speech so if you want
to learn how to do exactly that and make
it sound like you planned it you can
come to class with me and at the mile
straw workshop see you just just keep
going oh yeah I'm good at plugging this
[ __ ] that I love and I love the mile
straw flip it up lugging the [ __ ] that I
love anal sex anal sex and you will not
learn how to do those kind of jokes but
you will learn how to do a lot of anal
in fact I can't do anal sex we have a
problem baby we have a problem okay I
guess we were just not gonna get married
by Mel Gibson do you take this Jew to be
your happily wedded us that's gonna be
you because you like racist jokes that's
why I made it I do not like my sister
yeah that is a lot barely his show is
rosada fan of racist jokes oh and if you
want to come see me perform I perform
the second and fourth Wednesday of every
month at the clubhouse if I'm correct
those audiences they have to be straight
right like there's no Gabe Ebola they
can be whatever gender they want to be
and there's booze there for donation if
you want to come out and have a good
time and see some free comedy and we
love all who like comedy interesting and
some who don't like comedy we take all
comers not that kind of comment